i can't tell you how much i love this
film you know it's a good one when as
soon as it ends i
i watched it again like i i just wow so
much no i really didn't paul i think
this is one of my favorite performances
of yours ever it's so good um what was
it like for you
getting into the mindset of someone you
know having to come up to their family
their southern family in the 70s
um well alan and i talked a lot about
this um when when we when we first spoke
after i read the script we've both felt
really aligned on
on what the film was for
and who it was for and um uh
you know i i had similar reasons for
making the film as
as alan and very personal reasons and i
i feel like it was a very good motor
for me to generate the sort of energy
needed
to uh to try to um
to try to perform that yeah alan you
said that
this is one of the great experiences of
your life so
what is it about this movie that was so
special for you
um well the the story the the the script
the story itself is
is very meaningful to me personally but
uh
the the actual um experience of making
the movie with
with paul and sophia and peter and
everybody the
the entire incredible cast was
uh it was guerrilla filmmaking because
we didn't have any time we didn't have
any money
but we all were really invested and we
all really loved what we were doing
and um those experiences you know that
doesn't always happen
and uh i think i think it i think you
can see it in the movie is that it was
just a real labor of love
for everybody so yeah um paul i can
imagine there were some days after being
on set i mean you had some really
intense some emotional scenes you know
what what was that just whole experience
like for you
um well um
i'll i'll give you one example um
uh the the scene at the grave
alan we were supposed to be shooting a
wide shot first but alan could see that
i sort of came to the
certain was was ready to go and he
very cleverly uh and and uh you know
he's a real
empath or at least he pretends to be one
and
i'm so shallow it doesn't really matter
and he was able to see the state i was
in say no let's shoot the close-up let's
come
the the dp wanted the the sun was right
the light was right
he wanted to shoot the wide shot first
and then come in but adam realized
we absolutely should go and get the sort
of meat and emotion of this scene
and then after we shot the scene he sent
me home
uh and they shot other stuff but because
i was
he rightly surmised that i was not going
to be shootable
on after that and i needed to have a wee
round yeah he showed up and he was there
so i was like let's get it let's let's
you know we'll
screw the wide shot let's let's get this
because this is more important
yeah so that's awesome yeah awesome no
no keep going keep going no no
that that is the that is the answer is
is it there there was an empath on set
and and there often isn't an empath in
the place of
a sociopathic director which is
you know and so uh and he was able to
see that and and um and that that is
that that was sort of emblematic of of
how he dealt with the entire shoot
and if he doesn't put me in the other
all of his other movies
i will be furious oh you don't want to
get paul furious
no i don't you did not want to see that
no not to see that um and really quickly
obviously i know paulie can't say too
much about one division but
how much has the global you know
pandemic really affected production for
you guys
well we shut down for for it and then we
just we just finished um shooting what
we had left um
i think it was about four weeks work but
it took eight weeks
uh to do it um um it's difficult
to shoot now but you can
you you can make it work with a really
good zoning bubble system
in in place a lot of the joy has gone
out of filmmaking can't see anybody's
faces and so
you know if i can't see people laughing
at my jokes
being on set um but we got it done
and i'm really excited about the show
it's going to be uh
it's a really big swing and and weird
and i think people are going to love it
that's awesome are we going to see in
december i
can't possibly say but you should
be making well congratulations on this
film
honestly i i loved it so much thank you
thank you thank you morgan
you